a istoé e sim para onde eu posso nem que
eu posso eu posso tirar a bota fora
vocês disseram que eu tinha à sua espera
o que está pensado que eu nem fui eu o
lado pessoal de que forma a ajudar que
sejam muito bem vindos e nice e andréia
e mostrado chique fla-flu o um longo
longo eu vou tirar os fãs que está o
caraças mas só vai ser diferente e é
tipo um fascinante é fredes mas sem
sustos e só fornece fred que fui e
escondem alegre apenas felicidade amor
crime muito gostoso e e era o foco se
continuasse senadora embora lá jogar
final que vai parar a não estamos que
não vai eu preciso parar a música peraí
peraí tua paixão sonhos e assim tá
gostoso ficar pior filas fotos fotos
plantamos foi 1 mil km e pra quem não
sabe este o tipo 1 é pedir que é
basicamente ataca defende ataca defende
a apanhar aí temos de evoluir coisa é
equipe só que aí nós temos uma aventura
e temos módulo de parte ou seja jogar
com com a jogar como time é isso possa
me interessa mais difícil posição de
optar pela aventura enquanto novos
personagens como pode chegar a cair
assim é esta mesmo ok vamos ficar normal
o que temos de que a criação da equipe é
que vamos fazer duas equipas que a
equipa azul equipe rosa bom então pra
que posso vos clica em o boni sobre como
em resumo é faz todo o sentido
vou escolher um frango e porco freire
anel pedra onde eu tenho que ficar a 12
ok o fred é o melhor amigo do boné logo
e ostentação juntos né
o sonho eu eu acho que o povo mesmo
equipe original ou caiu foxy e agora
chica hoje é isso vai mesmo com a equipe
hoje é isso é agora a equipe rosa vai
que os neurônios mais recentes né
exatamente já assim o caetano está feito
o inglês do licha conheço meu inglês é
muito gostoso eu produzi estimado gosta
eu sei que tu tás com vontade de sair de
uma performance passear mas algo correu
muito mal hoje nem tudo estava em
animatrónica animatrónica tipo villa deu
só que aí nós estamos a trabalhar nisso
quanto é que algo está horrivelmente
errado tentar ver que estou a falar de
bizarras criaturas que estão por ali
a caixa não interessa a seu nós estamos
preparados para lidar com conceitos ou
com situações como esta e algo de muito
mau deve ter acontecido onde flipside no
lá fora algo assim vai ver o que
consegue encontrar mas tem que botar faz
questão de deixar um erro mas tu não
acredita
até aí há uma tarefa preto cumprir se tu
tens que deixar para pressionar o time
fred já gastei sim para onde é que o
poço não é que eu posso eu posso tirar
vocês disseram que eu tenho isso espero
que está pensado primeiro toque e pizzas
não vamos atacar com qualquer coisa vá
não tocará tôatoa carregar completamente
atua e não sei o que eu vou fazer ganhei
ok eu não sei eu sou um chill fred e eu
não sei o que é que eu fiz
ok vamos tentar falar com o zé manel
usou e mais uma vez eu não vou conseguir
passar a pronta agora vai além do que
está muito alto quando uma loja k este é
pra quem é quem o four seasons tio
editar mesmo estresse defesa ao
exatamente que desfez a 0 e supostamente
tipo em nosso que é o tanque o tenho eu
posso comprar este ano as coisas pra
ficar mais forte mas não tem dinheiro
tocando zero pois dobre até no jogo isso
pobre janeiro joão pedro 1 após saltar e
não não posso saltar não é mentira mas
estão enganados o que nós temos aqui
parte
após consultar a minha parte na soc tipo
que tipos não percebo tipos de batatas
já sabendo só vocês conseguem mais
vestiu deixem dicas e sugestões nos
comentários coisas para eu fazer o que
eu posso comprar o que é bom o que é mau
e não só exclui que me ajuda em taboão
o cabelo vai continuar então borboletas
tão fofa este mundo tem borboletinha só
que com chuva então este homem não tem
nada pra nós vamos tentar entrar nesta
cozinha eu não sei entrar em casinhas
nem ai cara não está muito alto o que é
que nós precisamos fazer vai ter vamos
pintar os gajos
agora vamos fazer é pensar william
sei que tati ou usar óculos e tinham
sequer vai fax e vai agora vamos fazer o
parto e fãs
meu deus pude fazer muito dano e agora
pinto através só vai conseguir matar o
meu tá muito fácil estou muito fácil tá
lindo lá em cima e não sei se é seguro
mas não encontrei a usar ou não porque
oferece um forte não vai ficar só pra
ver o que acontece
o uol canto dires phishing gol após
buscar aqui eu posso tirar ninguém de
peso pra apanhar coisas prêmios e se eu
conseguir apanhar a perna eu ganho
semfaz vertu cães
meu deus a equipe tem que resgatar ok
vamos buscar outro foco parque tão
rápida e está eu tenho que apanhar
apelos peraí peraí peraí parceiro que
vai ser aqui
calma é agora pelo agora espera o jogo
com a 5 apenas cinco tocantins né eu não
sei quanto dinheiro tem o tributo viu
meta ainda possui um mapa aqui o o dono
em cima aqui aparentemente estudante pub
uma da neve tanques cavernas nesta sc
cavernas têm que um celular relva
paraíso não sair um sítio como floresta
da floresta nós estamos ok aqui é tipo
uma planície assim é que é os céus não
me engano
lá o o oscilado blog e aqui é ter outra
caverna bem interessantes do joguinho
interessantes o cahia já não posso
saltar e conduz uma vez bolão bocha no
próximo para usar tem que andar mais
vezes que alguma planeta que está à
venda o que mandou disse ok temos uma
velha peru e que sabe o que faz
o substitutivo animais vocês podem ter
que fazem a extrema de eucride que
mancha mais barato custa 25 e eu só tem
cinco tocos por isso tão pobre que não
posso comprar nada não ter que apanhar
mais e um objeto vai ser tentar
juntar 25 tocando pra comprar pelo menos
é o que o bichinho vai ajudar a combater
mas vai que eu não preciso de ajuda é
porque estamos a falar muito bem vindo
num permanente o que esta casa tenho
nada esta casa não tem rigorosamente
nada como é que entra o que pode ajudar
não consigo entrar a musiquinha
foi uma ratazana além do hosp mata vai
fox vale da isso exatamente focar agora
na liga pisa através de web samu mata
burro é meu viram é pizza mata tudo meu
mato tudo ok já podemos ver nesta casa
agora eu não sei entrar nas casas
pessoal ajudem não consegui perder o
foco
a outra batalha sair mas nestas áreas
apesar da já que é isso estar perto
porque agora a banda de rock plebe gema
meu deus isso ao mesmo tempo é simples
mas já é confuso para caraças porque eu
não sei o que irá acontecer faz uma
entorse isso agora faz bonito outra vez
já está já morreu ao cair muitas levem
levem mostra o caminho
eu já ouvi falar com foco em mais um
mundial não pois esta é uma já tem 10
tocantins
mas quem eu posso comprar nenhum pilan
não é nada funciona por isso tinha que
ir embora de que vamos lá
ai ai apanhei outro não é isto meus
sonhos creche rosa maria matos caracóis
nobre da camisa e isso mata jato
marco maia já morreu né pois não é
preciso fazer nada mas muito bem este
está muito fácil cair vamos lá pra cima
se calhar lá em cima e consegui
encontrar alguma coisa de jeito aqui
neste lado existe alguma coisa ali
qualquer coisa já vi um dos olhos que
aquilo
apesar do mal outra vez mais fantástica
dezenas
aí mata tudo porque aí vai fosse dar com
gancho isso indica que mano cak6bk a não
está rindo o crédito da visa
vitor vai ter uns aí pera ai
autocomposição bernal bissau erro
mas as pesquisas foi isso já morreu
vai meu deus a toda mulher é pm pedindo
a apa não
ai já morreu os jogos é o pai mata outro
já fui porque outra vez
ok piso e outra vez só se for com 2
pescado jackson foto 1 vai embora e
julgados foi que nós perdemos uma pessoa
foi o foco em seu agora eu quando morre
na china aparentemente o caí bom é bem
chegado o peru que estou a presença do
brasil como a chave na época
vamos ficar para baixo então veio o que
encontramos um chavo del ocho achava
neto andas que sestak do machado ou
vamos entrar na floresta partida pode
opor embaraços eletrônicos troncos matem
os troncos são troncos curso
ae ataca dark pisar anos vai embora e
isso bem jogado
eu nem sei o que eu vou fazer mas tudo
bem que podiam ter vida pra mim é pedir
minha vida ainda nem com microfone agora
julgado à parte foi ver se a resposta ao
convite mas gado de uma das torres com
uma dentada bonito e espectacular para
qualquer um quero sair foxy fred com o
microfone e vai aos seus usos e agora na
época crítica para provar que eu tinha
uns 16 para aproveitar bem este jogo vai
mercado já só falta um pai que fez outra
vez pisou o pai já morreu e não está
vivo como isso foi xingado ok
voltamos a ganhar bem jogado e passar a
noite não opera o que é isso ou bando
foi forte e tosse
o estudo do microfone e agora visa
aumentar a linha morrer pedra fácil de
ambos quer agora eu tenho que tentar em
alguém a morrer faz o richarlyson é
exatamente aí vai ter outra vez do
country mês vai agora isso culpa da vida
eu não sei que estou fazendo meu ano foi
quem sabe se não ela vai das despesas
que isso vai matar não matou o ator bits
morte nem sequer vai deixar confuso
exatamente agora vamos ter tempo pra cá
que enchiam a estava indo ao campo que
estava em mictório através vale não fred
vai embora e agora só que agora eu faço
lá eu tenho um com um bolo de espera da
unidade com o esquenta para o que faço
não faz idéia
fazer a instalar alguém morrer ali
tauriel e morrer pé é pequeno é pequeno
da vida pois não precisa virar ae bola e
morreu
não pode ser não vamos ter que ligar
bole anda matovich vai conectar outra
vez eu não moro num foco more nós
estamos precisa vir a ganhar ganhámos
com o que esquenta ano tcheco ambos ano
o cristo é tão antiga
não pode ser néné isto já está montado
fora pra mim mel
ainda agora comecei a jogar já para os
nossos estudos vai cair para verdasco
pega vida bem estar do país caiu muita
atenção agora muita atenção da unidade
com este ano
victor andré cabeça fox se chama pisar
otis e eu acho que isso vai fazendo dano
que a vida toda e izraa também toca a
ibyte prisão eu pisar aqui a brisa fox
eu estava a aguentar muito bem não faz
aguentar muito bem e vamos vamos comprar
a vida prática cooperar e vida pessoal
ética morreu
o nosso personagem grávida morreu e
agora eu vou citar sodoma nelton da
mulher mata mata mata mata mata foi frei
cerveja único e june fred vai fazer e eu
estou confiante que passa me sinto assim
o microfone ai ai eu vou morrer eu vou
morrer e vai-vai fred mata da costa já
está no rio ave e equipar a aprimorar a
equipe morreram em segunda é isso a
cabeça já no sábado 11 com assim como
como sim na nené ataca manuel sutil que
já está aqui e eu não sei o que eu vou
fazer aquela chica não nomeou isso na
vida da vida bem jogado ok
o que chama talvez a mais uma personagem
já morreu o cancro pelo roque santa cruz
o anel vai matar tudo bem não fosse uma
xícara todos os oito personagens para o
que é que o que eu tenho que o balombo e
agora vai só vão chegar porque o
espírito eu não vou continuar muito mais
porque eu quero ler os vossos
comentários eu quero saber o que é que
eu vou fazer é pessoal eu tenho com esta
série propostas devem crescer muito mais
do que eu né antes que eu esqueça o
jejum de dois vídeos só do estanho logo
hoje mais cedo é um estrago está no
tanque trás por isso não viram passem
por lá o nome estado instituição é isso
ai furyk meta aproximam